شخصيه الرئيس التونسي الاسبق زين العابدين
بن علي ما ابرز الصفات التي طبعت او صبغت
هذه الشخصيات
ومنظم ادارين طبعا التكوين العسكري
الوقت
في الزمن يعني كم سنه مجلس الوزراء يبدا
الساعه 10:00 ساعه 10 ساعه 12
لا يتاخر يعني حتى المواعيد مع الاستقبال
الناس الى اخره هذا حاجه مهمه جدا كانت
كثيره
يعني يحب اطلاع على الملفات اي ساعه كان
يبلش دوره بكري يعني كان يسبقون جميعا الى
مكتبه شو بكرا يعني الصبح 6:30
[موسيقى]
يعني يعملها ولكن
الدوام الطويل اللي هو كان الشيء المفضل
عنده يعني في سنوات الاخيره احيانا يخرج
للفاتوره شويه ويرجع واحنا ما يرجعش اذا
كان ما عندوش عنده لقاءات خاصه الى اخره
همم كان رجل مثل اخلاق يعني
كل المواضيع
يهم
ثلاثه او اربع وزراء لابد من انه ياخذ
الكل وياخذه بطبيعه الحال همم
رايي الوزير الاول الذي هو همم
الحكومه كل من مع رؤساء السابقين الذين
خاصه الذين اطحت بهم ثورات او احتلالات او
غزوه او مشابه يعني كل من نسجل معهم يقول
كان هو متهم بالديكتاتوريه ولكن كل من عمل
معه يقول لا كان يستمع يعني على زين
العابدين بن علي وغيره من الرؤساء
السابقين يعني اشرح لي يعني انه انا
مستغرب شخصيا يعني مستغرب يعني
زين العابدين بن علي يعني لم تكن فيه صفات
همم الديكتاتور الديكتاتور انا قريتنا على
الديكتاتوريين في في التاريخ الكل من
نيرون اللي كان امبراطور روما حتى همم
جدد في القرن العشرين يعني ليه مقارنه هو
كان رجل منظم ااه صلب منضبط الى اخره
يستمع ولكن عندما يكون عنده قرار او وجهه
نظر مختلف يحاول ان يمررها
في نهايه العمره بان هي التي تستحق نهائيا
ولكن لم تكن دوله توصف بانها دوله بوليسيه
امنيه دوله قامعيه وهو يراسها
واي دوله ليس فما دوله ما فيهاش بوليس وما
فيهاش قائمه حتى الدولتين
الاذان
اتحدث
تونس
او قضايا بالمئات والالاف من
القضايا التعذيب ضد الاسلاميين من قضايا
قتل من قضايا الى ما هنالك يعني كل ما وقع
من قضايا هو رهن القضاء اليوم
وكل الدول تحصل فيه تجاوزات وحتى الان ثم
تزوجت